- [Narrator] Meet Mawson and Tingoora,
two adorable dingoes.
No, these aren't pet dogs.
They're actually wild animals.
Dingoes are Australia's wild dog,
considered a cultural icon
but due to interbreeding,
pure dingoes have become harder to spot.
Hence both Morrison and
Tingora's similar appearance
to domestic dogs.
Dingoes are thought to have
been introduced to Australia
three to four thousand years ago.
They are Australia's largest
terrestrial predator.
Dingoes hunt everything.
From rodents and birds to
larger prey, like kangaroos.
They are a big part of
aboriginal Australian culture
yet are seen as pests by livestock farmers
due to perceived attacks on animals.
Hunting for their skin and interbreeding
has left their population vulnerable.
This is the dingo.